un plaisir qu'on ne peut s'offrir au
salon du bourget ça soit gratuitement
dans le cockpit du grand frère du mirage
2000 le rafale son prix de revient un
milliard de francs l'unité
j'aime bien venir à ce tome hulot si
jamais préféré le mirage 2000 n ai
préféré le drama race album coup quand
même un avion qui vole coup mais qui a
du mal à se vendre seule l'armée
française on a acheté très exemplaire
est loin de ces préoccupations
commerciales ce qu'aime avant tout le
public du bourget ce sont surtout les
avions et les hélicoptères
mais rivière musi
qui font du bruit
on vas y prends l'avion
là je viens juste pour le bonheur de les
voir mais j'essaye pas de voir plus loin
de voir que ça c'est pour la guerre quoi
je ça j'y pense pas trop parce que je
crois qu'ils perdraient tout leur beauté
militaires ont peur et russes le sukhoi
30 de jeu le pour se confondre avec le
ciel et la mer mais c'est un autre
fouquereuil le 37 que viendra la seule
fausse note de la journée un
d'atterrissage bloqués
regardez l'avion va freiner brutalement
et devra revenir d'urgence au sol
côté civil l'avion le plus applaudi
l'a340 d'airbus pour airbus un salon qui
a été une bonne affaire
nous avons pu annoncer
71 commandes fermes et intentions
d'achat d'une valeur de 3,5 milliards de
dollars et puis à côté des gros aussi
les petits et même tout petits qui ont
lu un gros succès
feria vokoun qui admire tout seul